now remember I asked you to think with
me geometrically before you put pen to
paper and what this theme is I want you
to make a parallel what we've been doing
so far like see something like this
remember this instead of saying I your
distance from the origin when you put in
like you stuck some extra colleagues
numbers in here we say oh that's not
distance from the origin anymore is
distance from somewhere else from that
wreck does that make sense so what you
see what you see art said that's your
angle measure from the origin does that
make sense so when you look at this
you've jammed another complex number in
there right so this is no longer angle
measured from the origin it's going to
be the angle measured from yeah yeah
whatever you're subtracting right so
let's let's rewrite that to make it a
little obvious just like we did over
there it's the argument from that guy
beer okay so this is actually not that
hard I just need to find out where that
guy use and then measure the argument
from there that's like a zit words like
my new origin okay so let's draw this up
okay so there's one pulse to light your
heart of mine now if I just said to you
are our xia i z is equal to this angle
where would you start drawing your line-
pylon 3 what direction is that is it is
it my rotating that way remember to
heading this way which we're going
normally normally on the complex plane I
go anti-clockwise I start from here and
I go anti-clockwise but that midas means
you go clockwise you go down does that
make sense so usually I'd say oh you
start from there and off you go there's
your angle but I'm not starting from
here anymore am I I'm starting from this
guy does that make sense so what I do is
I imagined my for myself do you remember
who do not remember when you're doing
into unit when you're doing a compass
bearing question right and you're like
what's the barrier be from sea and the
bearing of a dove it whatever right you
guys remember how every time you've got
like an important point you draw a
little compass rose there right oh he's
a new point that I'm measuring from I'm
gonna do the same thing here so I'm
going to draw like a little compass rose
yeah cuz like hey this is my new origin
right when I see that I don't care how
this guy this is where all the
measurements come from and now I do my
minus plan of three just like that as if
I did it from over here um- pilot three
what angles that again that's going to
be 60 degrees so you can see it looks
like it'll be in this direction does
that make sense and you can say okay
pylon 3 is that angle Everett a
clockwise but that compass rose i put it
to imaginary compass rose yes i'm
eternally imaginary commissaris it's not
actual something's on the diagram where
am I going to put that pilot three if
there's pilot 3 here because this is in
the same direction as this and the plan
3 here should make a play on 3 here
because they're what kind of angles
their corresponding was on these
parallel lines do you see it so that's
what I'm going to throw in high on three
like
okay the last thing I want to know is at
the center of my imaginary compass rose
I've got one plus two I but I've labeled
with a hollow circle why is that again
yeah because if you're measuring from 1
plus 2 I then the angle at 1 plus 2i is
it's not well defined like which way
you're facing like I'm standing right on
top of that spot so that's why it's
Hollow there's no argument there okay
okay so sorry that that's question three
whiskeys question 2 let's have a look
okay yeah for also being fairly quick so
it's this one yeah I it's worth pointing
out I asked for us to draw all of these
you can find the equation of this you
can write I'm not going to ask us to do
it right now but how would you do it if
I asked you for an equation an equation
is going to be of some form like this
right do you go that I mean you could
phrase you could use any formula okay
but clearly the important things are
where am I going to keep the answers
right so I can extend this and what's my
grade you that's my Grady okay so how do
I work out where I'm going to hit the
axis well this color have a look up here
right if this is PI on three right then
this is poetry so what's this going to
be right angled right I think it's going
to be PI 16 yeah and I can use some
really simple geometry need to work out
what vast distance is I already know
that's too so then you can find out what
that value is and off you go okay so
there's your being I don't find em how
do you find gradient and all I know is
an angle I'm going to say M equals ten
it's on your reference sheet right
there's your theta don't forget it's
negative because this line is decreasing
so you're going to say m is equal to 10
of negative pi and 3 in fact we can do
that can't wait what is that a negative
is its negative root 3 isn't it I mean
you can even see it because our diagrams
like halfway decent it's either going to
be negative 103 or in a t-33 but it's
steep you see it's steep so therefore
negative root 3 looks like it's going to
be a go okay there's one more thing you
have to add though because you've got
your suppose you get this like it's y
equals negative 4 3 I said we weren't
gonna find the aggression but we can't
agree plus whatever but but this line
right it's online it goes forever in
both directions right and that's not the
locus that we've traced out right
because this is not a line it's remember
the right the road again I starts with
an R it's that summer and it goes it's a
raid okay so in order to say well
actually this is what I want I have to
restrict the domain right I have to say
that X is going to be to the right over
here of that it does that make sense so
you see you've got the equation and
you're like well where does this
equation work alright happy with that so
I was a good question Thank You Harry
fun play right let's all look at this
guy what is it said minus 1 is that what
I put is that what Ben each other ok now
again I'm gonna ask Rick posed the
question what does this mean
geometrically ok you're you're now used
to this idea of measuring an egg or not
from the center not from the origin
rather I'm measuring argument from these
two spots why we just draw those two
spots bursts let's just draw them where
are they which two spots am i interested
in negative I actually I should have
drawn further down instead of talking
call me and there we go that'll do okay
negative I and positive one right so
I've got this guy down here I'm actually
gonna that so their points okay should
make me follow everyone let's fix that
so think about this there are some Z's
there's a Zed somewhere there's a whole
lotta sets somewhere such that if you
measure the argument from here it should
be the same argument as if you measured
it from here where could you if you were
like standing like this is like a
basketball for you like when I should I
stand where should I stand such that if
these two guys looked at me they both
come up with the same argument ok now
we've seen the perpendicular bisector
before haven't we right it was useful
when we're thinking about the moduli be
the same ok because if for example you
stood here stuck here yo the modulus
will be the same same distance I can
stay here the magis been say we'd really
sound on Tuesday right however let me
just don't draw this because you're
going to make a messy diagram if I put a
point like that they're right and I now
ask negative I hey tell me what's the
argument at that point it will give you
an angle do you see where the angle is
it's gonna you got to measure from up
here you're going to measure up like
that ok and then there's whatever that
number happens to me and then you ask
one you asked this guy the same question
and you say hey can you tell me the
argument from your point of view from
your frame of reference what's it going
to tell me I'm going to measure up all
the way down this way right are there
the same arguments that's a dud right so
it's a great thing to test now I know
that's where I'm not where cried be
here's another way of saying it so that
when negative i am one look at me then
looking in the same direction if you
like draw a line
it's a bit long but that can't be in the
middle so that's why you don't want me
to be here so where do you would with it
like I like that continue that line just
anywhere on that line ah ok so if I
stand here and you can you can plot that
point now right and you ask negative I
tell me tell me what the argument is ok
it's going to say all right across I'll
draw my imaginary compass rose ok and
I'm going to cover example a very
friendly guys ok then you're going to
measure around and they'll say hey
there's my argument right and we some
size and then you ask one the same
question and heel measures argument and
will say yeah thumbs up right so
anywhere along here is great anywhere
along here is great am I done I'm not
right I can go in the other direction
just because I can go over here that
means i can go up here do you see it you
see it anywhere up here they're both
going to incline upwards as it were and
they're going to be looking in the same
direction yes so you can see this is
great like a very simple statement right
gives you this [ __ ] which you can
geometrically reason through